[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
camboya es de todo menos un país
cualquiera a sus espaldas acarrea años
tan duros que hicieron de este lugar uno
de los países más pobres y con peores
perspectivas de futuro de todo el
sudeste asiático
[Música]
situado entre dos potencias económicas y
demográficas emergentes vietnam y
tailandia este pequeño país de menos de
16 millones de habitantes tiene en su
haber una de las historias más terribles
crueles y despiadadas de todo el
continente y por qué no decirlo también
de todo el planeta
[Música]
en 1975 el partido comunista de camboya
tomó el poder durante los siguientes
cuatro años hasta su caída en 1979 los
jemeres rojos que era como se conocía
los miembros del partido perpetraron uno
de los peores genocidios que ha conocido
la humanidad durante la existencia de
kampuchea democrática el nombre del
estado regido por los jemeres rojos
entre un millón y medio y tres millones
de personas perdieron la vida como
consecuencia de sus políticas un cuarto
de la población de todo el país en tan
solo cuatro años
la persecución a la disidencia política
y a las minorías raciales y religiosas
constituyeron la mayor parte de esta
escalofriante cifra
y es que allí no se salvaban nadie
musulmanes cristianos budistas personas
de una u otra etnia cualquiera que el
gobierno considerarse enemigo de la
revolución era objetivo de la purga
[Música]
vamos sí que los jemeres rojos estaban
tremendamente chiflados y claro todo
esto hizo que las perspectivas de
desarrollo de camboya se verán truncadas
durante un montón de años porque como te
recuperas de semejante bestialidad como
podéis imaginar no es nada pero que nada
fácil y si precisamente de eso vamos a
hablar hoy en este vídeo de cómo ha
cambiado camboya desde el fin del
comunismo en el terreno económico y
también político y también sobre que
podemos esperar en el futuro de este
pequeño país asiático localizado en una
de las zonas con más potencial y futuro
de todo el mundo
atentos
una economía 100% dependiente
amigos de visual polític camboya ha
vivido en los últimos años un
crecimiento económico brutal exponencial
[Música]
entre 1997 y el año 2017 el pib ha
crecido cada año una media del 77 % el
pib per cápita se ha multiplicado por
más de 3
[Música]
i
son números de bandera pero en que se ha
traducido exactamente semejante
desarrollo
[Música]
pues por ejemplo todo este enorme
crecimiento económico ha hecho que la
población que vive bajo el umbral de la
pobreza se haya reducido de
aproximadamente el 50 por ciento a poco
más del 13
y claro con estos números estaréis
pensando vaya parece que en camboya las
cosas van muy bien no pues sí y no
[Música]
lo cierto es que en estos momentos el
país vive por así decirlo una gran
incertidumbre se encuentra entre dos
aguas entre china y los actores
occidentales eeuu y la unión europea
pero vayamos por partes
ya hemos visto el enorme crecimiento de
la economía camboyana durante las
últimas dos décadas así que la pregunta
que podemos hacernos en este momento es
que ofrece exactamente camboya en que se
basa su modelo económico
no es amigos la respuesta aquí es simple
industria textil y turismo
la potente industria textil camboyana
supone aproximadamente el 80 por ciento
de las exportaciones del país y emplea a
más de 700 mil personas con mucha
diferencia esta industria del motor de
camboya y la primera fuente de ingresos
de buena parte de las familias
camboyanas
por cierto un breve apunte camboya tiene
una característica que está dificultando
mucho su desarrollo y que puede suponer
un enorme problema para su futuro fijaos
[Música]
camboya sigue siendo mayoritariamente un
país rural menos del 25% de la población
vive en las ciudades lo que lo sitúa
como uno de los países menos urbanizados
del planeta para que os hagáis una idea
de lo que significa esta cifra su vecino
la os alcanza ya casi el 40 por ciento
en estas condiciones el acceso y la
prestación de servicios educativos
resulta algo muy caro y difícil de
gestionar la mayoría de los colegios
rurales no tienen libros ni conexión a
internet y la gente sigue mirando al
campo como forma de vida esto es lo que
explica porque aproximadamente el 20 por
ciento de la población adulta sigue
siendo analfabeta
pero no nos desviemos gran parte del
despegue económico de camboya ha tenido
otro protagonista un protagonista que ha
llegado con un enorme fajo de billetes y
ladrillos bajo el brazo pero queréis
saber quién se esconde detrás de esta
enorme lluvia de inversiones
[Música]
china lleva años invirtiendo cientos de
millones de dólares en infraestructuras
y también en el sector de la
construcción de la promoción
inmobiliaria ahora en camboya es muy
común ver paisajes llenos de grúas e
imponentes edificios y rascacielos en
construcción por todas partes tan solo
en los últimos dos años se han aprobado
cerca de 6.000 proyectos de construcción
valorados en más de 11.000 millones de
dólares y si amigos la mayor parte de
los compradores en este nuevo y
prometedor mercado inmobiliario vienen
de la propia china normalmente entre el
50 y el 80 por ciento de los inmuebles
de las promociones inmobiliarias más
lujosas de la capital con penn son
adquiridos por ciudadanos chinos
pero a qué responde semejante fervor es
que los chinos se vuelven locos por
camboya pues oye quien sabe igual puede
ser pero hay otra razón también la
escasa supervisión que este país hace
sobre la procedencia del dinero así como
sus laxas regulaciones esto ha hecho que
muchos millonarios chinos hayan visto en
camboya un refugio para su dinero ya
sabéis por si se tuercen las cosas en
china pero claro toda moneda tiene dos
caras y en esta historia no iba a ser
diferente hasta ahora hemos visto la
mejor cara pero qué ocurre con la otra
cara con la cara menos bonita
[Música]
juntos en china y la muerte de la
democracia hasta ahora os hemos hablado
de qué está pasando en la economía de
camboya pero no no nos podemos olvidar
de hansen primer ministro del país y
protagonista absoluto de la actualidad
camboyana hun sen fue uno de los
principales opositores al régimen
maoísta de los jemeres rojos y alcanzó
el poder en el año 1979 con la invasión
vietnamita que puso fin a la kampuchea
democrática y al horror de los jemeres
liderados por paul potts
desde entonces consentía va gobernando
el país convirtiéndose en el gobernante
que más tiempo lleva en el poder tan
sólo por detrás del guineano teodoro
obiang
a ver pues a simple vista la verdad que
un gobernante lleve tantísimo tiempo en
el poder pues no pinta nada pero que
nada bien no os parece
[Música]
pues veréis en 1993 un se aprobó una
nueva constitución que al menos sobre el
papel democratizaría el país
convirtiéndolo en una monarquía
constitucional con un sistema
multipartidista para elegir
democráticamente al primer ministro sin
embargo han pasado 26 años y de la
democracia ni rastro si la constitución
existe pero no hay oposición porque de
facto el propio régimen no lo permite y
en los últimos años la cosa ha ido aún a
peor
en las elecciones locales de junio del
año 2017 el partido opositor rescate
nacional de camboya logró un importante
apoyo popular sin embargo su alegría iba
a durar poco el tribunal supremo
controlado por el primer ministro ordenó
en noviembre de ese mismo año la
disolución del partido opositor y el
encarcelamiento de su líder que shock a
la excusa pues la de siempre en estos
casos se acusó a la oposición de estar
planeando un alzamiento así que tras la
ilegalización de la oposición y el
encarcelamiento de soca que llevó a
otros líderes opositores al exilio el
régimen de juntos en demostró que las
libertades políticas que promulga la
constitución de 1993 fueron a la hora de
la verdad simplemente algo cosmético
pero como seguro que nos sorprenderá
semejante atropello a la democracia y a
las libertades políticas y va a tener
consecuencias la cámara de
representantes de eeuu aprueba un
paquete de sanciones contra altos
funcionarios de camboya la unión europea
inicia el proceso para golpear a camboya
con sanciones comerciales y es que es
esto último lo que más daño puede hacer
la camboya las sanciones comerciales de
la unión europea aunque en realidad no
se trata de sanciones propiamente dicha
sino de la retirada de camboya del
programa europeo todos salvo armas un
programa que beneficia a los países más
pobres dándole acceso al mercado europeo
mediante la exención de aranceles lo
cual ha ayudado enormemente al
desarrollo de la industria textil
camboyana
pero claro para poder aprovecharse de
estas ventajas comerciales hay ciertas
condiciones y una de ellas es que se
aseguren los derechos humanos y las
libertades políticas y democráticas y es
precisamente por la violación de estos
principios que la unión europea se
encuentra inmersa en pleno proceso de
expulsión de camboya de esta iniciativa
lo que puede poner en peligro buena
parte de la producción textil la
principal fuente de ingresos camboyana
cuyas exportaciones a la unión europea
suponen unos seis mil millones de
dólares alrededor del 40% de las
exportaciones totales del país
y ante semejante amenaza lo lógico es
que juntos en dirá marcha atrás no
creéis pues no nada más lejos de la
realidad
hun sen no sólo se reafirma sino que
culpa a la unión europea' de
entrometerse en asuntos internos pero a
ver a ver un momento porque si hay un se
parece que le dan igual las sanciones y
este jaque a la economía camboyana
estará entonces el primer ministro
condenando al país al desastre
bueno podríamos pensar que sí pero la
realidad es algo más complicada lo que
juntos en tiene realmente en mente es
reducir la dependencia en occidente
girando hacia china es más las
relaciones con pekín son tan buenas que
el apoyo es mutuo
veréis mientras china junta al régimen
camboyano con ayudas e inversiones
camboya apoya a china en las
resoluciones de la asean que condenan la
expansión militar y territorial de pekín
en el mar de la china meridional y si
creías que esto es todo no estás
equivocado esto no acaba aquí
atento según informes china firmó un
acuerdo secreto para estacionar tropas
en camboya si si habéis oído bien hay
importantes indicios de que china podría
terminar abriendo una base militar en
camboya una nueva base militar china en
el extranjero
veremos cómo acaba con todo esto amigos
hay algo claro un sens se ha convertido
en un hombre de pekín y está dando la
espalda occidente es el último jugador
en hacerlo pero ahora turno para ti qué
te parece que china esté apalancando su
poder en el sudeste asiático a base de
talonario incluso a costa de perjudicar
las libertades políticas debería juntos
en retractarse y ser más neutral entre
occidente y china cuéntanos qué te
parece en esta encuesta y déjanos como
siempre también tus comentarios aquí
abajo y si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte a visual polític para estar
al tanto de todas nuestras novedades un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]